la batalla del donbass en severo meza
amenaza con dejar atrapados a cientos de
civiles que hay en esa ciudad hay más de
800 personas en los pasadizos de la
planta química de azotó una situación
que recuerda muchísimo lo que ocurrió en
la acería de mariupol en severo don es
también las diarias rusa está arrasando
por completo la ciudad han expulsado a
las tropas ucranianas del centro de la
ciudad han bombardeado varios de los
puentes que daban acceso
para poder evacuar a esos civiles y el
que queda está bajo fuego cruzado entre
ambos ejércitos es una situación muy
complicada como decíamos y peligrosa
para todas las personas que todavía
están allí resguardándose de esos
bombardeos en este contexto el
presidente ucraniano selenski ha vuelto
a pedir una vez más más armamento pesado
más artillería para poder hacer frente a
ese avance lento pero muy destructivo en
el este de ucrania de las tropas rusas